so how's everyone doing today
cool welcome that was uh very
unenthusiastic
but I'll forgive you it's three o'clock
on a Friday
it's close to uh well I won't say what
time I tend to say because I'm being
recorded and it's got an F-bomb in it
but uh
actually it's got another bad word on it
too so anyhow um
so welcome everyone uh to understanding
probabilistic data structures with a
hundred and twelve thousand and 92 UFO
sightings
my name is Guy Royce I'm a developer
Advocate at redis there's really not
much on this slide that matters uh
there's something on there that will
matter to you there's something that
matters to me
and there's something that matters to my
boss
any guess which thing matters to my boss
that uh come on point or get over there
that redis logo right there
my job is to go out and say hey redis is
cool and it does things like that you
might not be aware of how many here have
used redis before
a lot of you how many have used it for
something other than a cash
more than all usual uh
most people it's the cash it's got
getting sets well I'm going to talk
about today uh probabilistic data
structures which is the thing that redis
does as well I'm going to talk about the
data structures really more than the
redis but I'll show you how to do it in
redis as well so that's the part that
matters to my boss the part that matters
to me is are those social media links
there well maybe the Twitter account
doesn't matter as much as it used to but
um but you know kind of matters to me a
little bit I guess but I I sort of Judge
my value as a human based on how many
people follow me on social media and so
uh please do me a favor and give me a
follow
the part that matters to you the
important part is that github.com guy
Royce URL uh there's lots of code and
repositories all my all my talks are
archived out there so if you want to go
check stuff out afterwards and play with
this that is a good place to go
I will point out that yes I do have a
domain name of guy.dev
which I think is probably the most
badass thing that I've ever done in my
entire life
for the low low price of 180 a month a
year not a month a month well that'd be
a lot wouldn't it 180 U.S a year so
um but yeah so
112 092.
this is kind of a surprising number it's
a surprisingly large number it's a
surprisingly precise number this is the
number of UFO sightings I have in this
wonderful data set uh called that I I
pulled off the internet 112 000 and 92
UFO sightings in North America from
about 1950 to about five-ish years ago
uh this data is glorious and wonderful
I've got I got it off off this website
called data.world
and it was screen scraped from the
National UFO Research Center
um
by this wonderful user of that website
named Tim Renner and he scrapes uh UFOs
sightings from their website made a big
CSV file with 112 092 lines in it a 93
count in the header
and um he that's what he does he likes
weird data he scrapes the stuff and he
does data science against it he did it
with Bigfoot sightings he did it with
UFO sightings he did it with haunted
places he even did it with dog Man
sightings I didn't even know Dogman was
a thing
I I guess he's a dog man
and um what he likes to do with them is
do data science and do interesting uh
discoveries he used the Bigfoot sighting
data and to try and figure out where
Bigfoot tends to be found
and he did some clustering on it to find
out geographically where it's at and you
get these unusual structures these
clumps of Bigfoot sightings and then he
realized that you could find Bigfoot in
the woods
um
because those sites corresponded to
densely pot densely forested areas he
did a bunch of things to figure out
where the UFO sightings tended to happen
any guess where UFO sightings tended to
happen the most often
within 50 miles of U.S Air Force bases
shocking right
the number one day for UFO sightings in
this data set
it's a North America mind you July 4th
Independence Day
you know with all the fireworks
dad is that a firework uh no son that's
a UFO
the second place by the way was New
Year's Eve so
yeah he does important important work
and so he has made all these ridiculous
talks that I do possible because he
screen scraped some silly sites to do
some silly data science and so now I'm
going to use this data to show teach you
about probabilistic data structures
the data's got it's not particularly
brilliant you've got a summary it's just
text describing the UFO side citing
briefly three saucer shaped ships
easy for me to say
a high in the sky metallic but no shine
rather dull gray they hovered overhead
in a V formation
yep sounds like a UFO sighting we've got
the city and state that happened in the
U.S so this one happened in Salem Oregon
the date and time in ISO 8601 format so
this happened in September the 15th of
1950.
uh the shape of the UFO sighting uh some
there's a whole bunch of shapes that
they can be in and disk is one of them
and triangle is another and
and light apparently is a shape that
they use to classify UFO sightings get
your duration which is just this little
thing expressed for humans it's not a
precise minute seconds it's just 15
minutes or about 20 minutes that sort of
thing the link to the site at
thenewfork.org
where you can read the reports the full
text of the sighting
by the the eyewitness account and a
latitude and longitude of the city where
it happened
so this is fun data you can do all kinds
of fun stuff like with this
so this is the data we're going to use
to explore probabilistic data structures
um
but what the hex probabilistic data
structure has anyone here ever used or
heard of a probabilistic data structure
before show hands
exactly right I did a survey to find out
on Twitter
this is very scientific 119 people voted
and I asked uh who all have you heard of
probabilistic data structures
and he's doing this when I was putting
together this talk because I wanted to
get a feel for just how well known they
were
about 60 percent three out of five had
never heard of them
at all
so you're in good company
about a fifth of them had heard the term
I suspect most of them had heard that
term in the question
we're sometimes literally minded aren't
we
uh 10 roughly knew what they were and
ten percent had used them so we're
looking at like one out of five people
had any idea what a probabilistic data
structure was and only half of them had
used it
so if you don't know what one is
you're in the right place you're in the
right company this is pretty normal
so you're ignorant that's great that's
why you're here
um
and so did this Define what a
probabilistic data structure is I'm
going to go to their evil opposite their
the evil twin deterministic data
structures
now you all know what deterministic data
structures are may not have called them
this but you've used these before these
are the linked lists and the sets and
the arrays and the hash tables and the
graphs and the trees and the cues and
and all those structures that we use all
the time probably the one you've used
the most is Hash table and list because
almost every language has some variation
of of that
um
and they're called deterministic data
structures because
they do what you tell them to if I put
something into a list
I know that when I ask for it it will be
there I think I can get it back out if I
put something in a hash table I know
that it will be there if I delete it it
will be gone
that's what it makes it deterministic
does what you would expect
I'm going to look at
hash tables in particular and the reason
I'm going to do that is because a not
all of you have taken computer science
courses
I I hadn't B the ideas behind a hash
table are actually uh very useful for
understanding probabilistic data
structures because they take advantage
of hashing algorithms quite a bit as
well
and so we've all used a hash table right
we might not know that we've used a hash
table if we took computer science and
data structures class we wrote a hash
table
but it's our basic key value pair if
you're say a.net developer which I
suspect is a good majority of the room
we call these dictionaries
if you're a python developer it's
dictionaries if you're a Java developer
you have my sympathy
and we would call these hash Maps
and if you're a JavaScript developer
like me
this is pretty much everything
everything's just a hash table in
JavaScript
and it's just your basic key value pair
right you yeah you put a key in and say
I want my city and then it's got a value
associated with them this key is
associated with another value we've used
these
but why are they called hash tables
well because they use a hashing function
and we've all heard of hashing functions
probably as well but lots of times we're
thinking of them in terms of
cryptographic hashes so you know I need
to create a hash of my uh my blockchain
blah blah blah nfts something something
right uh you use a like a Shaw 256 to
encode something and get a
cryptographically secure hash
but all hashing function does is it
takes data
and turns it into a number
it can take a little bit of data it can
take a lot of data some hashing
functions require some sort of seed or
salt
here I'm showing here you've got on the
left
some data here and a randomly generated
seed and if you put that data with that
seed you will always get this number on
the right ouch
this data up here is the bytes making up
the name Scully
in utf-8
and
that's sort of hashing function do they
they turn a pile of data into a number
of a fixed width
and then we can consistently always get
that number when we run that data
through there so it's deterministic
and this is useful if you want to
get a signature without having to store
the entire document
you there used to be way back in the day
you would store all your passwords this
way and like your Etsy password file or
whatever it was and I think it was using
md5 at the time but
and so hash table then uses these by
creating a an array of linked lists so
on on the right here
we've got an array I've got 10 items in
that array each of each of those items
in the array is a linked list
and when we want to add a value to the
hash table
we take the key that we want to use the
city
we run it through a hashing function get
out a number
we
get the modulus of that number equal to
our index how wide our index is so we've
got 10 items so we have modules at 10
and that gives us an index for us to put
that value into
so when we add City we want to add this
Salem the value Salem to the city
property on a hash table we go through
that process and shove it in there and
we add that Salem to that linked list
that's how we add to a hash table
we're going to add another thing here
we've added to the state of Oregon
and so we hash State we get the number
four and set when we hatch City we've
got the number one and so we put Oregon
in position four
etc etc
occasionally
you will get a collision
there's only 10 items here we will
probably won't put more than 10 things
in our hash table
and so this is why these buckets are
linked lists this is why this is an
array of linked lists so what we do is
we just add it to the next item in the
linked list and then we walk that linked
list to find it
so if we read from this hash table if we
want to read the city we hash the city
get the index go to the linked list walk
that linked list until we find the city
and then we return the value
make sense
for those who I did this really fast and
so those who've taken data structures
classes like yeah this is review and
then the rest of you are like I kind of
get it don't worry it's fine
the key thing is is that we're hashing
these key names and we're hashing data
and then we're using that as an index
that's a property you'll see over and
over in the probabilistic data
structures
so when we pick our deterministic data
we uh we're often making trade-offs
between the time complexity of that data
structure and the space complexity of
that data structure
so if you uh for example want to use a
linked list
linked lists are great because they're
very compact
they store they use exactly how much
memory they need to use no more no less
however if you want to find something in
a linked list you have to walk that
linked list to find it and so they have
good space complexity but they have bad
time complexity their time complexity is
O of n for reads and is O of one to
update
whereas something like a hash table
tends to have you've got this array and
it's got empty pointers that aren't
pointing to anything
and so it's got a little bit of wasted
space but finding things in a hash table
is an O of one operation and so the
lookups are fast uh but it's wastes a
little bit of space whereas an array or
a linked list the lookups are slow but
it's very Compact and so we make these
sorts of trade-offs when we pick our
data structures all the time
um
but it's not the only trade-off we're
making because there's capabilities in
these data structures as well so like
the arraylist is actually really quick
to add things to so if I want to add
something to the tail of a linked list
it's very fast it's very easy if I use
an array arrays have o of one for
modifying values they're fixed size so
they just take up what they take but if
you need to resize them that's difficult
and so we don't just choose time and
space we also are choosing the
capabilities of these data structures
like some data structures work well
for certain scenarios and others work
well for other things that I want to do
and it's but it's not just time and
space there's another option we can have
when we're looking at our data
structures of ways that we can uh
another trade-off we can make other than
just size and speed
and that's accuracy
so a probabilistic data structure is a
data structure that's making a
compromise against accuracy we are
saying I want something that's really
small and really fast
but that lies to me sometimes
that sounds crazy right why would I want
my data structures to lie to me well
because I need to count really big
numbers maybe or um
well basically because you you need a
scale
and the accuracy just doesn't matter
let's say uh you're a
video streaming service or video hosting
service whose name ends in tube
and you uh
you want to count how many unique
visitors unique users have watched a
video
how would you solve that with a
deterministic data structure
you would have to put all the usernames
in a set
oh what if it has a million views
a million unique users viewing it or 10
million or 100 million what if it's
Gangnam Style
it's got like how many it had like a
billion views or something like that
they weren't all unique but
I know I at least watched it four times
well that structure is not going to work
but you don't need to know that you had
exactly 10 million 917 305 views you
could be off by a couple percentage
points
and it's still going to be perfectly
usable because that exact count isn't
really the important part this is the
kind of trade-off you're making when
you're making an accuracy trade-off and
so that's the idea behind a
probabilistic data structure I'll get
something that's less accurate but I can
get a couple of order of magnitudes in
time and space savings
it's a good trade-off
and this is a trade-off that you've made
before even if you haven't used
probabilistic data structures
this is a jpeg
of
of the Devil's Tower in Wyoming in the
Badlands in the U.S
those of you who are old enough to uh
remember this scene from uh with Richard
Dreyfuss and mashed potatoes may
remember why I picked known why I picked
this image
it's a really cool place
and it was very prominent in Close
Encounters of the Third Kind
and this pixel right up here
that one right there the blue one
you see it yeah
it's actually the wrong color
why well because jpegs are lossy that's
that's something compressible and they
make them smaller
and then in the process of making them
smaller we lose a little bit of the data
we lose a little bit of fidelity a
little bit of accuracy in the original
image
but it still just looks like a blue sky
and so probability probabilistic data
structures are a little bit lossy but
good enough that's that's when you use
them that's when they make sense
a lot of probabilistic data structures
can be thought of as unusual sets with
limited capabilities
and when I say sets I mean the Venn
diagram things right you can get the
union and the intersection and the
difference and test for membership and
cardinality and all that kind of stuff
uh and the ones I'm going to talk to
today are all about all can be thought
of as sets with limited capabilities
you can
test a set for membership
so here we have a set of star square
circle and triangle these are totally
not all the shapes in the redis logo
foreign
and the question is is the square in the
set
well yes yes it is
is the Pentagon in the set
no it's in Washington DC
and so that's a question of membership
is this thing in the cider knot
you can have a probabilistic data
structure that's optimized for
cardinality for counting
how many unique things are in a set this
would be the fill in the blank tube
example I gave earlier
I've added a bunch of things to the set
there are only unique items in the set
how many unique items are there in the
set so we've got a star Square Circle a
triangle there are four items in the set
so it's cardinality of four
I could have a probability data
probabilistic data structure that is
good at telling me the frequency of
items in a set
within a certain degree of accuracy and
this is where the set analogy breaks in
ever so slightly because I know that
sets technically only have unique
members and I'm saying here that it has
five stars four squares six circles and
three triangles but the idea is there's
a numeric value associated with each
entry in the set and increments as you
add items add duplicated items to it and
this can count at the frequency and so
you can get an idea of well how many
squares are there in this set or how
many how many circles are there in the
set
and if you can do frequency you can also
do uh ranking and this is similar in the
idea that you can say well give me the
top so many things in the set or this
item what's its position in the set and
you can do that probabilistically
without necessarily knowing the count so
frequency is about knowing the counts of
things
probabilistically
ranking is about knowing the Order of
Things
and the accounting we don't have
accurate counts but we know the order
so these are things you can do with
these sets
you can also compare sets of data
we're going to look at similarity later
on when we look at minhash and we can
say how much a set is like another set
and can I just say I absolutely love
this photo it's probably my favorite
photo in the entire set of random photos
here
so uh there are a lot of choices of
probabilistic data structures I just
kind of went out to Google and found a
collection of them out there and and
to populate a list here and looked into
what the basic ones are but there's a
lot of options out there we've got
this little list here the ones that are
highlighted in blue are the ones we're
going to be talking about today so we're
going to talk about Bloom filters heavy
Keepers and Min hash
uh the ones in Gray we won't be talking
about
the ones with the little um
Red Cross dagger thing
right up here
like that thing right there those are
part of retta's Stack
which is redis with a bunch of extra
data structures and I'll mention that in
the next slide and then the one with the
little double dagger here a hyper log
log is part of vanilla redis
so balloon filters and cuckoo filters
I'll let you check for membership
a hyper log log counts things it does
cardinality hyper log logs actually
particularly cool because it's 12
kilobytes and you can count the number
of unique atoms in the universe with it
which is kind of neat
and uh within like a I think a 97 point
there's like a fixed accuracy for it
count sketch and count Min sketch are
about getting the frequency things
Q digest and T digest I haven't looked
at Qi digest that closely T digest is
like a probabilistic Time series
and so it can fill in it can interpolate
values that might be missing
uh heavy keeper is uh part of top K
which we'll look at later it's all about
tracking
uh how big a data coming in and how it
flows over time so you can use it to
find things like uh trending topics or
like which IP addresses are engaged in a
dial service attack against my uh my
server that sort of thing and the Min
hash and Sim hash will do similarity
where you can do uh
you can do like a document similarity
comparison and I'm I think minhash was
created by Google back in the 90s maybe
early 2000s I can't remember they were
using it to determine whether they
should crawl a page again or not if it
changed enough
so we're gonna look at three of these
the two that have redis capability I'll
go ahead and demo some Reddit stuff with
them for minhash it's not part of redis
it's just kind of cool so I won't demo
that but
these probabilistic data structures are
available as part of redis Stack
right a stack is the redis that you know
and love
with extra capabilities modules that are
plugged into extend it and so they add
new data types and new commands there's
a Json one to do Json data types search
lets you search those Json redisgraph
which is a graph database in a key
redis time series which stores time
series database in a redis key and the
one we're going to talk about today a
bit is redisbloom which adds
probabilistic data structures to redis
you can get to redis.i read a stack at
redisley it's honestly easier to Google
write a stack than it is to type that in
that's what I always do
so
advertisement done
Let's uh let's take a look at Bloom
filter
and hopefully I have enough time to get
through all these
so a bloom filter tests for membership
it can say no
and probably
so I can add all kinds of things to a
bloom filter
and then I can say is this thing in the
bloom filter and it will say no it is
not or yeah it probably is
Bloom filters are fast they're really
fast everything's over one
and they are of a fixed size when you
create them so they don't grow at all so
I guess they have a size complexity
equal to O of one as well
and you would use a bloom filter to um
it's two big use cases for Bloom filters
that I can think of that I thought of
when I was rehearsing this an hour ago
um one is if you wanted to get unique
usernames for a website let's say you've
got a website with a lot of users
I mean maybe something like Twitter or
something I don't know and you want to
see if that username is taken
well you can't exactly do select star
from users where username equals
username I'd like to use that's not
going to work with you know tens or
hundreds of millions of users
but you could shove all the usernames
into a bloom filter and then ask the
bloom filter is this username used yet
or not
and if it says no then you're good to go
you use it if it says maybe
then you just don't let anyone have that
username
and now you've got
a nice fast way to determine whether
username can be used or not you can also
use this for data deduplication if
you've got say uh imagine a file full of
you know thousands of documents you
could run them all into a boom filter
and if it says I haven't seen this
before
then
if it says no when you add it I have not
seen this before then you can say this
one's good if I have seen this before
then I should look at it and see if it's
a duplicate or not
so you can use it to dedupe data as well
a bloom filter's got two main parts
it's got some hash functions with their
corresponding seeds again these are not
cryptographic hashes these are probably
murmur filters or something like that
and it's got
a bit array of a fixed width
when I add something to a bloom filter
for example I want to see whether I've
heard this UFO sighting before or not
Megatron in the bushes this is great
story about these uh
I'm going to say kids but they were
probably in their 20s
who were driving along the highway I
think in New Mexico
and it's it's in the data set I actually
pulled these out of the data set and
they just pulled off to the side of the
road
because they needed to take care of an
important and necessary bodily function
probably because they had too much beer
to drink
and they're going back behind one of the
the sagebrush there and they hear a
weird sound they hear like the a
Transformer transforming they hear
Megatron in the bushes and he goes like
and they freak out and they hop in their
car and they take off and then lights
chase them from behind the mountains for
60 miles
and I'm sure they totally weren't High
these sightings are so much fun to go
looking through I can't recommend it
enough anyhow so we want to see if we've
seen this one before so we're going to
add it to the bloom filter because we've
just received it and we can check later
to see if we've seen it so we add it
there we take the data
and we run it through our hashing
functions
and we get a number because that's what
hashing functions do
we modulus that number with the width of
our Bloom filter which in this case is
10 because it fits on the screen
and then everywhere we have we now have
indexes into that array and we set them
to one
so we set it zero five and six are now
set to one
we've added something to the bloom
filter the data is gone it's all hashed
away but we we have like the
Fingerprints of the data in the bloom
filter now if we want to say have we
seen Megatron in the bushes before we go
through that same process we get the
same indices and then we look and say
are these all ones
if they're all ones then probably
if there's a zero in there we've
definitely not seen it because otherwise
that would have been set
I'm going to add another one I seen a
UFO when I was about 13 years old
the yelly case was in the original data
file so
this actually happened in my hometown of
Columbus Ohio
which is was totally random I just saw
honestly I was just scrolling through
the list of UFO sightings and I saw the
one in all uppercase and then it got my
attention and so I put it in the slide
but then I found out they were in
Columbus and that was extra funny so in
this case we run this through the same
process we get different indices but one
of them is the same
I've circled it up there in in green
right there
and so we set positions one and two to
one where they were zero before and six
sweet don't do anything to because it's
already set to one
so we've added another item now if we go
and read this we get all ones back if we
go and read
Megatron in the bushes we get all ones
back and so the balloon filter is still
telling us correct things we've got a
set in 10 bits
that's telling us
this I've seen this before I've seen
this before
now where it starts to break down
is when you get Collision this is where
it gets probabilistic so we've added
another sighting here investigators for
the Bigfoot field researchers
organization I just happen to know
that's what that stands for
observe a glowing green blue sphere
and this one completely intersects with
where there are ones already some of
those ones are from Megatron in the
bushes some of those ones are from icina
UFO but this doesn't change the state of
the bloom filter
so if we add it
and then query it and say have you seen
this one before
the Bloomfield is going to say probably
if we don't add it
and ask the bloom filter have you seen
this one before it's going to say
probably and so whether we've seen this
or not is kind of well it's
probabilistic
if we had done this in other orders
it would change the nature of this
because it's probabilistic
and so um
this is pretty much how a bloom Filter
Works is that is that resonating with
everyone any questions so far yeah
that's a phantom
way yeah that's actually a fantastic
question it was a point I meant to make
and forgot so thank you he's a plant
[Laughter]
now um yeah that's actually the
trade-off so um the more hashing
functions you have the less impactful
occlusion will be because you're not
going to get 100 overall you're less
likely to get 100 overlap on that
Collision
um but then the wider you need to make
your bid array
so the more hashing functions you have
the wider you want your bit array the
smaller your bid array the fewer hashing
functions you need but then the impact
of that Collision is more significant
there's actually a formula for figuring
out the optimal thing for this just use
this easy math
I didn't take a lot of math in school so
I actually wouldn't know how to do this
but it's not as awful as it looks what
you can do if you want to do this
manually is you can just uh pick you
know how many items you want to store in
your Bloom filter
by the way it's worth mentioning here if
you look here
if you keep adding things to this
eventually this will fill up
and it will be all ones
and then it will be
full of lies
it will always just tell you
it's like yeah that's probably in there
yeah it's probably in there
it's it's like an American it's just
always says yeah sure
right yeah so if you have more hash
functions you've got to have more bits
to compensate for it or there's capacity
for total number of items you want to
store is greatly diminished
um well that's what this calculation is
for actually
um in redis we actually will keep track
of it see if it gets too full and then
we'll create another one and another one
and another one and then it impacts the
performance because then you have a
second Bloom filter check
uh but but you know but it keeps it from
it being a problem if you're coding one
of these up yourself you just need to
well you just use this math here so what
you do is you pick like a number of
items like I think I need to store a
billion things in my Bloomfield or 100
things whatever
and uh and then you guess at a number of
bits
and then you compute the number of
hashes for K down here using the bottom
formula
and that will give you a and then you
use that to solve for p to give you a
false positivity rate
and then you say is that good enough or
not
and then you adjust
so that's how you can do it if you just
want to use pen and paper and do the
hard way there's websites that will
calculate this for you which is the
better way
um
and um
if we use redis it will just like I said
take care of it I'm going to do a quick
demo here with redis
just to show that this stuff is real
okay here's redis I'm gonna go here
I'm using a tool called redis Insight so
I'm going to say BF that's for
bloomfilter DOT add or no I'm going to
set one up Reserve
and then I want to give it a key we'll
call it bloom
because I have imagination
then we'll set an acceptable error rate
so I'm going to go with
0.001 so I want one in a thousand so
99.9 accuracy
and then I need to say how many items
let's add let's say this is going to be
for a thousand items
I now have
a bloom filter Retta said okay
and so I can do bf.add
bloom
and then I can add what should let's
just do food bar Bass
now we'll do alpha bravo charlie that
feels more ufoe
so do Bravo
and then let's let's let's do a
a check then so once we've added things
we can say bf.exists
Bloom and if we put in Alpha
we get back a one down here saying that
hey that does exist
if we do something that doesn't exist
we get back it should be a zero this
thing renders zeros as nil so if we go
down to here we can see the same thing
exists
Bloom Charlie
here integer zero
so that's a super quick Reddit demo of
using a Bloomfield and redis I have a
sample code for Bloom filter out in the
GitHub repo for this this talk uh
there's not a lot they're actually
really easy to code up I mean you
literally have I did it in JavaScript so
it's inefficient and I actually
literally use an array of booleans which
is like the worst way you could possibly
do this but but it was just to show how
it worked so
let's get this back up
okay and this is just showing you the
syntax I just showed you it's not
complicated
sure absolutely
so all that was doing was using that
calculation that was here
but yeah it will over time and and so
it's at a particular capacity or below
on average it's going to be that
accurate but it's not it's not an
absolute
thing but all redis is doing behind the
scenes there is this takes that error
rate and then uses and plugs it into
here and figure and does the algebra
let's see
can I
so balloon filters are cool
uh we're going to talk about Min hash
next
uh minhash is used to determine how
similar documents are
using set similarity
so set similarity
itself is something I want to talk about
before I talk about turning documents
into sets and before I talk about
getting the similarity of documents and
so you can get the similarity of any two
sets of data using a simple calculation
called the jaccard similarity
all you're doing here is you're taking
the cardinality of the intersection
that'd be how many things are in the
intersection and dividing it by how many
things are in the union or divided by
the total number of things so here I've
got scalder and Molly
face swapped friends from the X-Files
and we have states in the United States
in which they've seen UFOs skalder has
seen them in a California Nevada Oregon
Wyoming New Mexico and Ohio
Molly has seen them in Florida Kansas
South Carolina West by God Virginia New
Mexico and Ohio
the intersection is New Mexico and Ohio
Area 51 Hangar 18 sounds legit
and so there's two in the intersection
there's ten total these sets are 20
similar
that's it
basic math
um
but we can't apply this to documents
usually like how could we do this with
the document can we take all the words
of a document
and just make a set of all the words in
one document and all the a set of all
the words in another documents and their
similarity is going to be really high
because they're both written in English
and so that's not going to tell us
anything to let us compare documents
and so uh to turn documents into sets so
that we can see how similar they are and
then to do it probabilistically after
that
um
we need to do a process called shingling
shingling takes trigrams sets of three
words
overlapping
and makes a set out of those so here we
have we notice two
notice 2R
to our left
and so on until we get a set of all the
trigrams that overlapping programs in
that document so we noticed to our left
further off in the mountains a bright
glow this is from Megatron in the bushes
and so if we do this to documents we can
now compare these sets of trigrams and
see how similar they are and those will
give us an actual meaningful similarity
with our documents and so here we're
doing that we've got skelter's report
and Molly's report both going to Skinner
to find out uh you know how you know
compare the results of what they found
in the field
and if we do uh the Jacquard similarity
calculation on these sets uh we get an
intersection of seven a union of 11 and
these have a jaccard similarity of 63.63
repeating percent
so this is more useful but this has a
problem too
any any guess what it is
performance
uh you are storing a lot of strings
these these sets are bigger than the
documents were originally
and uh and comparing all these sets
together is really intensive
and so Google came up with a better way
to do this
using a Min hash
so the Min hash is calculated once again
using a hashing function with a seed
and we take every single trigram in the
report there so all these here going
down
are fed through a hashing function up
here
and across to create a set of numbers
for each trigram so number 325 in this
first set here
right there is we notice too 489 is
notice 2R all the way down to 312 which
is the mountains a
and then we do this for each hash and so
we end up with a set of numbers for each
hash function for all the trigrams
that we then take for each of those sets
the smallest value in each one
which is why it's called Min hash
and so the minimum hash for each hash
function
for the set of trigrams in the document
and we end up with and since we use
three hashing functions we end up with
three numbers 233 143 and 102. this is
much smaller and tidier than
easier to work with than the big giant
bunch of text
we do the same thing for malt for Molly
Smith hash and calculate a similar value
and then we can take these sets and they
act like document signatures
and we can compare them using jaccard
similarity and get a number now this
number is 50 similar and that's mostly
because I picked three things I have
three hashing functions you probably
want to use more
um
but this will show you how much how
similar something is probabilistically
it's not as accurate as you're going to
get by actually counting the trigrams
but it'll give you a good feel for how
similar these are you could use this for
detecting plagiarism
and saying well these are have a high
similarity
uh you could use this for doing what
should I bother to recrawl this web page
because has it changed enough for me to
justify re-indexing it
um and the nice thing is is that you can
just you don't have to store the
documents that you use to generate your
Min hash you can just store them in hash
and then you go to another document
generate another Min hash that using the
same seeds and compare them
and so you don't you can you know if
you're Google you don't have to store
the entire internet to in to know
whether you've indexed the page or not
so Min hashes are kind of neat I
actually ran into someone at a
conference uh late last year who said we
were doing this other thing where we
were just picking random parts of the
document to see if they'd changed or not
it's like I should probably be using
this
like wow that's the first time anyone's
ever actually needed this
kind of neat but it's a little you know
esoteric uh I used to work for an
insurance company and you know you don't
really need to do this when you're
working in an insurance company right
but it's still pretty cool stuff
so that's uh Min hash I don't have a
demo for men hash I do have an
implementation out of my GitHub repo
that you can go check out last but
certainly not least we've got top K
which is
um I say it's actually a heavy keeper
it's called top K and redis but it's
using a data structure called a heavy
keeper combined with a Min Heap
and uh what top K does is it ranks items
and so and and it stores them in a way
that can erode
so you could use this for I mentioned
this earlier for IP addresses that are
hitting your server so you you know you
get the top five most common common IP
addresses that are hitting my server and
those are going to change over time as
you know someone stops hitting my server
with that IP address it needs to fall
down the ranks as newer ones come in
or trending topics where trending topics
are coming in different hashtags and
over time
they get mentioned less and less and so
they drop down through the ranks and
more current topics uh bubble up
and so uh top K is great for this
I already mentioned it it's a Min Heap
and a heavy keeper I'm not going to go
into how a Min Heap works
uh but we'll talk about a heavy keeper
a heavy keeper this is probably the most
complicated of the data structures I've
talked about so far I think it's
probably the most complicated and the
ones that redis offers in redis bloom
um
but a heavy keeper has once again
unsurprisingly a bunch of hash functions
with seeds
right right over here
so we got three because three fits on
the screen
and on the the actual structure that
stores all the data is a
an array an array of just two values the
array of buckets I guess we could say
and that bucket has a hash a place for a
hash value and a count so it's just got
two integers
and we have a number of these arrays
equal to the number of hashing functions
and when we create a new one
everything's empty so the hash is null
or zero the count is zero
and the uh the hash functions have newly
created seeds
and this is going to count how often
whatever you've added to it is in there
it will count and it will keep
incrementing those counts but things can
come in and erode those counts and
reduce them and so this will always give
you
then the correct number or less
so this this is actually kind of a bad
counting algorithm
but that's not what it's for it's there
to support ranking
and so we want older stuff to get eroded
well I'll show you how it works and this
will make a little more sense
so we're going to put words that are
used to describe the shapes of UFOs into
here
and so
object is a popular description of a
shape of a UFO perhaps the least useful
one
I saw an object in the sky what was its
shape it was an object
and so we're going to add the word
object we put it into those hashing
functions
and we get
a hash value out we modulus that with
the width of our buckets
of that array we get an index here we
get 2 1 and 2.
and then we make a decision we look at
the position of the index
and if there is a zero which all of us
have for the count and the hash is not
populated if it's null
then we can claim ownership of it and so
the word object with a hash valve of
4062 or 5062 can claim spot 2 in that
array and so it puts its value in there
increments the count from zero to one
and we do that with all those
hmm
if we're adding something and there's
something there already
then we make another decision we we come
in we add object a second time
and we look there and say well is the
hash value that I stored in this bucket
the same as the hash value I just
generated
yes okay well that's mine increment the
count
so now we've added object to here twice
and so it reflects two it reflects that
counts
when we go to read this
All We Do
is we go through the same process we
give it the word object it creates the
hashes it finds the indices and it looks
and says find all the the rows where the
hash matches the hash
and then give me the biggest number
so here object matches all three of
those all right over here
and they all have a two
so
the count is two
let's add something else to it
so we add the word light
also a popular UFO shape
and this goes through here and gives us
different hash values for the different
hash functions and gives us different
indices for the first two rows so in row
number one
uh it finds an unclaimed spot and so it
claims and increments it by one row two
finds an unclaimed spot increments it by
one but in row three there's something
there already and the hash numbers the
hash values don't match
so what happens
does it take it over
well what happens is it's going to
decrement
Maybe
so um
we will do some math to determine a
probability as to whether we will reduce
that count by one
without changing the hash if we reduce
it to zero we've got a new empty slot
that someone might claim later
and so uh the way we calculate that
is uh
taking B which is a magic number that we
use when we create our data structure
and the count to the power of negative
of the count so in our case negative two
B needs to be a number that's
greater than one but really close to one
so I picked 1.05 you can do 1.01
whatever whatever you want
uh the bigger that number
uh the more the more easily things will
decay
I think I may actually I may have just
said that backwards don't don't take
that to the bank
um so here we we got a magic number of
1.05 to the power of negative two that
gives us a 90.7 chance of it being
decayed if there was a lot of things in
there
let's say we had 10 000 as our count
1.05 to the power of negative 10 000 is
a very small number
and so the likelihood of decaying would
be really low
but it would Decay over time
and so we're going to say that 90.7
might as well be 100 and we're going to
go ahead and Decay this what this means
is that the counts can be eroded over
time and this is why it works for like a
trending topic because as I add topics
into here
uh
as topics are not mentioned anymore they
slowly get eroded away over time and
then the new ones come in and start
replacing them so it keeps the heavy
things and then and then throws away the
little things and that's that's why it's
called a heavy keeper
so uh here what decay has occurred light
has not claimed to that position
it's still associated with object
but we can query it and still get
accurate numbers so let's query uh the
word lights and we find the count for
light it matches in two rows in the
third row we don't have a match
and so we take the largest number there
that's a one so we've added light two at
one time which is correct
for object
we have
a match on all three of them but we have
different numbers we've got two two and
one now two is the largest so we return
the two and so its count is still
accurate and whenever this happens
whenever we add something to it
we update A Min Heap
which is the thing that actually stores
these strings that we're carrying about
the IP addresses or the
uh whatever whatever the value is that
we're trying to get the top K of and so
the Min Heap is updated and resorted
each time and so if we want to say just
give me the top five items then it just
goes into surrogates them in Heap we're
going to get the counts then we can use
the heavy keeper
there's some redis commands around this
you can call Top K dot Reserve I'm going
to skip this here
top k.reserve lets you set one up and
say I want to keep track of three things
100 wide
five hashing functions and the Decay
right there is the in the reciprocal of
the one I used in my example
you can add things
it does what you think it does you can
query things which will say is it in the
top K and it'll say yes or no
you can count that will give the count
from the heavy keeper it's almost always
wrong
and you can do a list to get the things
that are in the Heap
so I have built a silly thing that uses
this in redis
and I've got this data set that I
mentioned earlier with all these
probabilistic data structures in it it
is right here new forkreports.csv watch
it crash there we go
um
yeah
112 000
101. I must have something wrong maybe I
got my number wrong on my presentation
so those are all the sightings these are
out here in a zip file in the git repo
actually and I've got two little python
programs one reads through all these uh
see the CSV files pulls out the shapes
most commonly used shapes and the most
commonly or the shapes that are in here
in the CSV and the summary and then
parses them out and adds them to a heavy
keeper
I'm not going to go through all the code
because I'm getting a little short on
time but you can go check it out later
if you like this basically is using uh
nltk to pull out stop words so the top
10 words aren't a and the or that kind
of stuff so you get more interesting
words and then I got and it just and it
uses a
uh pandas to do a lot of the CSV parsing
so and then I've got app.pi which is
just a simple little flask app which
exposes some endpoints to um to return
uh what the top 10 shapes and the top 10
words are with corresponding counts so
it's not complicated code you can go
check it out and see I'll do this from
python there are examples of some of
these probability data structures in
JavaScript and c-sharp and Java and in
the repo as well what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go ahead and run this
so we'll do python
python
we'll say build.pi
and this is going to start reading that
CSV file
and it's now it's adding to the balloon
filter or to the uh the heavy keeper the
top k
over here not going to turn my Bluetooth
off
we'll do python app.pi
and that is listening on Port 5000.
so if we got to redis
insights here
go to the Keys and refresh it
me in big in this a little bit
close the CLI here we see that we've got
uh there's my Bloom filter from earlier
here's the UFO words and UFO shapes if I
go over here and I can do a command I
can see like uh uh top K dot list
UFO shapes
and then it spits out what are currently
the top KU top 10 UFO shapes white
circle triangle disk sphere other
unknown formation oval and Fireball
those are all shapes I believe right
and I've got a little website here that
is Let me refresh it
oh come on
127.0.0.1
this totally worked the last time I did
it
okay
we'll use Firefox
no just run Firefox dammit
I literally rehearsed this right before
I came here
skip this step I no no I
skip this step
this is exciting demo isn't it
just let me browse damage
okay 127.0.0.1
there we go
so I got a little web app it's just
pulling that server and it's going out
and and uh getting the latest count
every second so
stupid useless and fun
that's what that's how my wife describes
me
so
let's go ahead and
get back to the slides there
so this part of this is to show this
stuff is real that's really why I tend
to do the demos
um
if you want to check out some of these
resources all the stuff's out in the
GitHub repository there's a bloom
filters by example uh blog post that was
fantastic helped me understand them and
the little calculators out there as well
there's a Min hash tutorial which is uh
honestly the bulk of where I learned how
minhash has worked he did a great job
heavy keeper there's a white paper out
there I translated that into code and
slides so that you don't have to
the UFO data settings data set sightings
data sets out there the newfork.org is a
real website
um I didn't make it up I to have the
patience to type in 112 092 UFO
sightings uh we got a blog post on on
redis.com by my co-worker Ariel who
wrote the uh actually wrote the data
structure for top K and then redis Bloom
is at redisbloom dot IO and you can get
redis insight at redis.com redisinsight
um
if you haven't figured it out yet I work
for redis
we've got a Discord server so if you
have redis questions you can hit us up
on discord.gg redis usually I'll be the
person answering the question but there
are others uh and uh there's about I
think we got about five or six thousand
people on the Discord server already so
it's pretty active
free classes on redis at
university.redditis.com
and you can sign up for a cloud version
of redis that has all these
probabilistic data structures baked in
at redis.com try free and if you use
code stack 200 my boss will know that
you saw my talk
uh for those who uh didn't get and want
to get all the code slides there's a QR
code
it will never give you up it will never
let you down
and that's pretty much what I've got I
always try to leave it up there for a
bit for everyone to grab the picture and
so I'm stalling